we are live a lot to discuss I'm just
going to wait a couple moments for
people to connect going to be talking
about the DNC chair election going to be
talking about some of the stories that
are going to be on tomorrow's program
just a ton to discuss and I've been just
researching stories the last couple of
hours and many many many many many
stories to discuss i'll be talking about
the White House blocking some media
outlets from the White House press
briefing room I'll be talking about
Donald Trump CPAC statements about
anonymous sources I will be talking
about a completely imaginary Swedish
defense adviser the showed up on Bill
O'Reilly program and the expected
apology that I think we're gonna get
tomorrow night okay so super chat is on
we'll be doing as usual live shout outs
and thank yous to people who sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership during
the live stream a lot of stories to
discuss and glad everybody's here uh
okay uh number one this is sort of
interesting I recently sent out and I
have here the first one a few years ago
I did FOIA requests Freedom of
Information Act requests to the FBI NSA
a whole bunch of different agencies and
got basically responses from all of them
saying we're not going to tell you uh
whether we have or don't have anything
on you but what we're telling you is we
don't have anything on you that we are
legally required to send you and they I
I did another round of these and they
started coming back in as you can see
here department of justice the the
entire thing here this one is from the
FBI and they're basically saying that
they have nothing for me that they are
required to provide me under the Freedom
of Information Act laws however I should
not interpret this letter as a statement
that there is no name a file with my
name and or that I'm not on any watch
list they're saying
from what they're legally required to
tell me there's nothing that they're
actually going to be telling me okay so
that's one interesting thing hopefully
i'll get some others CIA NSA others
coming in soon basically what i expected
okay number two i received uh i didn't
receive actually my girlfriend received
because she's a registered Democrat and
i'm not let me just make sure there's no
information here yeah um this official
2017 Democratic Party survey okay uh and
the questions here I think the main
point of sending these things out to
people is to raise money because it does
come with something that says uh please
please donate money but it's a survey
that purports to care about what what
Democrats want and that asked about what
domestic issues are more important to
you international issues it has a
section called the Republican agenda and
it asks like which of trumps hundred day
priorities uh do you think are the most
important ones to block uh what do you
want the legislative goals to be the top
priorities for the Democratic Party as
the minority in Congress and I don't
know I have a hard time with believing
that this thing is anything other than
just an attempt to raise money and if
you see on the back page here at the
bottom basically they they just want
money and that's really the main thing
so I think that this entire thing really
is just to raise money I don't know call
me crazy it's not my impression that the
Democratic Party really cares that much
about what my girlfriend's legislative
priorities are as far as far as that
goes okay so a couple things there
hopefully we'll get more of the FOIA
requests back from people soon okay so
we talked about the DNC survey talked
about the FOIA request step stuff okay
I'm going to get into some of the
stories I'm looking at for tomorrow's
show once again super chat is on feel
free to send super chats if you want we
have a coupon code for a discount off of
membership that coupon code is I voted
17 and you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership and on that
note big thank you to Peter Slattery who
just signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership Peter Slattery becoming one
of
the record at this point something like
four hundred and fifty two new members
this month at david pakman.com slash
membership more than doubling the best
month previously so big league stuff
happening there okay tomorrow on the
show i mentioned this on a prior
livestream i will be up talking about
more aspects of the russian blackmail
dossier of Donald Trump that have now
been confirmed uh I already mentioned
that before so I'm not going to get into
that in detail there's an interesting
article in the washington post about how
dot we shouldn't be surprised that
Donald Trump's um uh White House is in
total chaos because as a CEO it was also
chaos and that the washington post
article exposes a lot of that ok so we
may have time for that tomorrow some of
the stories i will definitely be
covering tomorrow the democrats are as I
I now I'm calling the Democratic Party
Democrats incorporated because that's it
it really feels like it's it's it's just
the business of being the Democratic
Party Democrats have elected Tom Paris
as DNC chair defeating keith Ellison 235
to 200 ok and the if you haven't been
following this the idea was that keith
Ellison was sort of like the Bernie
candidate and Tom Perez uh who didn't
announce his candidacy for basically a
month to the day after keith Ellison did
Tom Perez is the sort of establishment
guy right the the Hillary aligned
candidate and indeed and I'm going to
talk about this tomorrow there are 18
different emails in the wiki in the John
Podesta WikiLeaks emails there are 18
emails between Podesta and Tom Perez and
and we're going to talk about some of
those and really what they confirm is
what most of us know right which is that
uh Tom Paris was a big Hillary supporter
doesn't necessarily mean that he's bad
for the Democratic Party but he's part
of the establishment that believes that
you need to have a sort of Republican
light Democrat in
order to win and I fundamentally
disagree with that and I'm going to
argue tomorrow on the show that this is
a decision that ideologically you know I
look at my eye look at my facebook feed
and I see tons of my friends who are
really really concerned ideologically
about the new DNC chair ideologically
keith Ellison is basically the same as
Tom Paris but the difference is sort of
the view of how they see the Democratic
Party uh-uh going forward and I think
that this is not good ideologically I
don't think it's the disaster that many
of my friends think but I don't think
that this is good and this doesn't mean
that I love everything that keith
ellison stood for right i mean there are
areas where I disagree with keith
Ellison he's been on the show I've
interviewed him before but we're gonna
dig into that tomorrow thank you too
Frank mccright who just sent a
five-dollar super chat uh you can use
the super chat feature anytime you want
and uh questions comments anything you
want to get out to the audience use the
super chat by all means feel free and
big thank you to Charisse Walker
Charisse Walker just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership she did use
the coupon code i voted 17 that saves
you forty percent off of membership you
get a hundred percent of the benefits
for forty percent off of uh forty
percent less money and who can't get
behind that okay and speaking of the
bonus show so um uh associate producer
Rachel Gordon we announced maybe three
or four weeks ago she had taken a full
time job and would be leaving the david
pakman show and last night we had a sort
of little going-away thing for Rachel
and after this thing I was walking to
sort of back in the direction of where I
live and and the subway with david
pakman show producer pat and a couple of
other people and we witnessed what i
would consider the the biggest car
accident that i've seen a happening like
i've driven by worse accidents clearly
but the worst car accident that i've
seen happen and it involved a car
stuffed with uh with with people and
it was gonna be an interesting bonus
show tomorrow okay let me put it that
way so that that and more on tomorrow's
bonus show and of course all members all
subscribers at david pakman.com slash
membership get instant access to the
bonus show and all of that other great
stuff so please sign up and if the
normal rates are a little high use the
coupon code i voted 17 okay thanks to
courtney haynes who sent the five
dollars super chat no comment no
question just sending a five dollar
super chat thank you very much alright
let's get to some more stories i will be
discussing in much more detail including
the leaked audio that we now have
related to the White House blocking
certain media outlets from the from a
press gaggle in Sean Spicer the White
House press secretary's office on Friday
we now have Sean Spicer on video between
the election in the inauguration saying
that the Trump administration was not
going to be banning individual news
outlets lie okay so that that didn't
happen we also have a quote from Sean
Spicer where he said that it is
dictatorial dictatorial to start banning
individual media outlets and we have
leaked audio from in that room where
when Sean spike we were led to believe
that this was not an ideological list
although when you look at the list you
had breitbart one American news their
piece of work and the washington times
in the office and then you had CNN
Politico the New York Times BuzzFeed and
a few others out you're telling me that
it wasn't ideological anyway we have
Sean Spicer leaked audio from Sean
Spicer and it confirms everything that
we suspected which is indeed that uh it
was completely ideological and because
the White House doesn't like the stories
that are coming out from some of these
media outlets so we're gonna dig into
that with leaked audio tomorrow and it's
so bizarre once again we have now two
people from Fox News Shep Smith and Bret
Baier saying this is nuts the this this
is bad and and when Fox News becomes the
voice of reason not really but kind of
when Mitt Romney and George W Bush seem
comparatively a thoughtful compared to
who we have in the in the White House
you know something weird is going on uh
Clark 1234 has sent a five australian
dollar super chat saying do you think
that YouTube will eventually d monetize
more videos and lower the CPM so
political channels become less viable
answer in spanish know what why would I
answer in Spanish nobody would
understand what I'm saying uh I think
that uh we've seen a slowdown in the d
monetization of video so there was what
I call sorry I just hit my mic I hope
that wasn't annoying for people we saw a
um an increase in the number of D
monetized videos some months ago and
they typically related to something like
war terrorism certain key words seem to
trigger it so what we've done is we're
not really covering different stories
were still covering the same stories we
would cover because that's what I do on
the show I cover what I want that sort
of the whole point of not having someone
tell me what to cover and what not to
cover but we're a little more strategic
as far as the key words that we use so
if we talk about a story regarding
terrorism we might try to avoid the the
keywords war and terror and maybe just
use the countries and I don't know the
the the religions that are involved
we're sort of dancing around it you know
what I mean ok so that that's that's the
answer that as far as lowering CPMs to
make political channels not viable I
hope not I mean we've been looking at
that's an interesting question let me
look at our soo i was looking at our
CPMs over the just over twenty seventeen
because january usually starts slow for
people who don't know what we're talking
about when we talk about a CPM CPM it's
cooked it read basically means it you it
used to mean cost per thousand but now
it's really just used to mean how much
ad revenue do you make per thousand
views and on youtube that sort of
differs pretty drastically depending on
the vertical that you're in vertical
being are you in technology or news and
politics or whatever and if i look at i
don't know let's let's see how how how
far back i can look CPMs were
CPMs are kind of I mean yes CPMs are
down I guess relative to what what they
used to be but it hasn't been a
continued decline the way that some have
suggested at least you know and that
this may be skewed because we're news
and politics and during 2016 being an
election year it sort of went up so i
don't know i mean i hope that listen a
part of our business depends on youtube
revenue so i hope that that doesn't
happen um nice 2347 sent the two-dollar
super chat saying how much longer do you
think this will go on David it depends
what you mean I don't know um I don't
know what exactly you're referring to
but if you mean Donald Trump being the
president it could go on for quite a
while because again uh whether its
constitutional issues or issues of
conflicts of interest whatever uh it
depends on a Republican House to really
start investigations and I don't know
unless Trump's approval rating gets down
into the 20s maybe even I don't know if
29 will do it it might have to be mid to
low 20s I don't know that Republicans
are going to be too eager to investigate
him EG sent a five-dollar super chat
saying David would you consider your
channel and unbiased news source i watch
you in Sargon for opposing views on
Trump actions love the show I didn't
even know that Sargon liked Trump I mean
I don't I don't know that much about his
specific political views i I've he's
interviewed me I've interviewed him or
maybe not maybe I've only interviewed
him I guess he hasn't really interviewed
me listen so there's a couple different
things we have to talk about bias and
and unbiased everything you watch has
bias okay now it could be institutional
bias if you're watching corporate news
where it's it the lens is sort of a
what's how do we need to relate to our
advertisers type of bias you might have
over over political bias in terms of on
the political spectrum but i think that
there's significant confusion and sort
of a lack of media literacy around these
issues so first of all when you're
talking about bias bias is not
necessarily that's that there is opinion
right i mean i do a progressive show it
is an opinion show I don't pretend
that what I do is report news in a
so-called unbiased way we don't even do
original reporting this is analysis and
this is a liberal show so am I unbiased
in the st. in the sense that I pretend
to be neutral absolutely not but what we
also have to distinguish between we have
to distinguish between neutrality and
objectivity and neutrality is typically
a concocted or fabricated veil okay
because there's really very there's very
little actual neutrality but what we
want to pay attention to is objectivity
if I were to come to you and say I'm
going to give fifty percent of attention
to climate science believers and fifty
percent to climate science deniers on
paper I'm appearing to be neutral but
there's nothing objective about that
because the overwhelming science on
climate change is that of climate
science belief not climate science than
that denial okay so objectivity
neutrality bias we've got to understand
this stuff out we've got a ten-dollar
super chat from isaiah row says my
parents and family worship Trump call
obama and hillary communist my dad is
called hitler and Kim jong-un liberals
and they despise gays and think black
should be swinging from trees any advice
okay that's a pretty tough situation
that's some pretty serious serious stuff
isaiah i think that if my primary advice
would be it's probably healthiest
emotionally not to engage in political
discussion with those folks okay that
that's probably that's probably the UH
the best way forward if you want to
engage in politics with them i would
suggest questions like what Peter
bogosian recent recently suggested we
did an interview with Peter bogosian
which I recommend you check out where he
said you may want to start with
something like what evidence could I
give you that would change your mind
right so if to go back to the the
specifics Kim Jong hoon is a liberal
okay i would say what would change your
mind what evidence i'm not saying i have
this evidence but if I did whatever
would change your mind that Kim jong-un
is not liberal and they might say well
if you could show me that conservatives
act the way that Kim Jong hoon acts uh
that would change my mind and then you
could put together a very very long uh
uh series of facts and sometimes facts
don't matter about how actually these
authoritarian autocratic regimes are
far-right regime regimes are not far
left regimes but if you ask this
question if you ask this question of
well what evidence could I give you that
would change your mind about kim jongmin
being a liberal if they say none then
you go to uh well okay so you're not
operating in the world of facts and
that's a sort of different conversation
okay and I'm paraphrasing and you can
you can check that out but I I would
sort of approach it that way and try to
get emotional distance from it yourself
and don't make it about what you believe
but make it about how the other person
has established their beliefs okay so a
few a few thoughts there couple of other
super chats going by two dollars from
Courtney Haynes with no comment two
dollars from nice 2347 what's your
biggest concern with Trump nuclear war
uh I actually don't think its nuclear
war my sense is that I hope there are up
there are people who would get in the
way of nuclear war I'm more concerned
about just fundamentally altering this
has already happened but it could happen
even more fundamentally altering what
counts as reasonable politics for the
United States of America to engage in so
uh and and that could that's that could
prove incredibly embarrassing all right
let's see if I need to block any people
I see a bunch of people saying that I
need to block Renee um okay yeah Renee
is doing a lot of homophobic slurs in
Spanish I guess I'll block that seems
worthy of a block why not I've said it
before I'll say it again the band button
is free and if people are just going 1
comment after another after another uh
yeah it's not fun for anybody all right
it just isn't and yeah i'm looking at
maybe bringing in some irregular
moderators into the the youtube chat and
it's funny because we are so so
liberal when it comes to the blocking
stuff if you look at the comments the
YouTube comments not like the live chat
comments but the comments on our uh
videos on our are not live videos almost
anything goes I mean it takes a lot for
someone to get blocked uh and yet still
people are breaking through that and uh
and and getting attention that makes
people want them to be blocked during
during the live chat so okay anyway we
will we'll deal with that as needed but
before I get back to some of the stories
will be talking about tomorrow thank you
to our Jay Adams who signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership the coupon
code for forty percent off as I voted 17
number one funding source for the david
pakman show Elliott bonsall Elliott
bonsall also doing a membership with the
coupon code I voted 17 you can sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership and
lastly frank mccreight frank mccreight
also signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership membership is normally
six months six bucks a month oh sorry
Elliott says bonsall bonsall okay
Elliott bonsall I apologize membership
is normally six bucks a month or 60 for
the year okay if that price is too high
just use the coupon code I voted 17
you'll save forty percent you still get
all of all the member benefits and
tomorrow on the bonus show we will be
talking about a pretty bad car accident
that producer Pat and I witnessed last
night and a lot more okay Andre meuse
nice moose sent a five-dollar super chat
saying hi David hello uh okay let me
tell you about another story we're gonna
deal with tomorrow do you remember okay
let me let me go back a little bit the
trunk administration has had this I
guess I would call it a trend because
it's happened at least three times now
of making up terrorist attacks that
don't exist in order to prove some kind
of point or push some kind of policy and
one of those was when Donald Trump
recently talked about did you see what
happened in Sweden last night and of
course nothing happened in Sweden
nothing at all happened in Sweden and
Donald Trump ended up tweeting that he
got that story
from Fox News ok so Fox News instead of
saying oh well you know we don't know
what the hell doll Donald Trump is
talking about Bill O'Reilly doubled down
and went in uh to do a full fledged
jumping the shark interview with a guy
that was presented as a Swedish defense
advisor okay bill o reilly interviewd
Nils built who was uh called Swedish
defense and national security adviser
and he of course showed up and said it's
a big problem uh it we're were concerned
about immigration Sweden blah blah blah
blah and actual swedish national
security and intelligence and
intelligence uh experts started looking
into nils built and they said we don't
know who this guy is this guy is not
anybody that we don't we don't know
about this guy at all and it turns out
that this was an imaginary swedish
defense advisor people started looking
into the guy it turns out he hasn't been
in Sweden for like 25 years he also is
not an expert on Sweden I mean just
completely fabricated and supposedly
tomorrow night Bill O'Reilly is going to
comment about this there's going to be
some kind of commentary made about this
and I'm looking forward to that so just
stunning absolutely stunning what's
going on on Fox News and just making up
experts amazing okay people calling for
more blocking happening in the Chad who
needs to be blocked here someone named
Peter people are calling for blacks but
blocks not blacks Peter Arnold there are
racist comments about blacks a Freudian
slip there Peter Arnold david pakman is
lying now I don't think that that's ban
worthy I mean he can say that I'm lying
people can judge for themselves you can
you can look up these stories and see
what's going on okay what's next Michael
Rogers this support is in honor of the
Sweden and Bowling Green massacres very
clever is this I think I may know who
that is let me just see I won't I'm not
going to out this Mike yes it is Mike
it's so good to see Michael Rogers and
some people may actually know who who
mike is sending a very very clever
at supporting in honor of the Sweden and
Bowling Green massacres of course both
non-existent okay here's a few other
stories that I'm looking at four
tomorrow and we basically have a time
for depending on the duration of the
interview that we do in tomorrow we're
interviewing attorney Mike Papantonio
about his blockbuster victory over
DuPont in a trial about ten ten days or
so ago so I already told you about one
two three four five six stories ok it's
Sunday night I already have six stories
ready for tomorrow's show and I have 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 15 more I mean this is
the this is the era of Trump where it's
not even clear what to cover Trump City
saved the billion dollars on Air Force
One jets the Air Force doesn't have any
clue what the hell Trump is talking
about okay yet another one of these
fabricated stories we've learned that an
aide to Donald Trump was heavily
involved in forging ties to Hungarian
anti-semitic groups this is someone now
that is advising Donald Trump possible
story Donald Trump asked the FBI to stop
looking into that Russian dossier thing
which is increased we increasingly know
that it's a not only does it exist but
much of what's in it is true uh my
friend Ryan Clayton who I know from just
activism and whatnot he showed up at
CPAC and handed out Russian flags to
people that said Trump on them of course
Trump is so low information that they
didn't even know that they were Russian
flags eventually they were confiscated
by CPAC brilliant trolling absolutely
love it my phone ringing there I don't
get why are people calling me can't they
see i'm streaming here Trump doesn't
seem to know the difference between the
debt and deficit that's a story millions
of people could lose health care
coverage based on the new Republican
health care proposal a majority of
Americans want Congress to investigate
Trump's contact with Russia so many so
many stories I mean just truly truly
unbelievable the number of stories that
we're looking at for tomorrow let's look
at some of the super chats that are
going on Courtney says how
can we improve critical thinking skills
in America do you think a lack of such
skills affected the election yes
absolutely we should be teaching
critical thinking skills in school and
it should be just a fundamental part of
education there are many state education
boards including the one in Texas that
don't want that happening I think we
know why ok so we absolutely need to be
teaching critical thinking starting very
very early on ok Patrick sending a five
new zealand dollar super chat hey David
thoughts on bill maher's latest show
where he says that news became clickbait
which made it easy for Trump to claim
it's fake news haven't seen that that's
interesting though that's very very
interesting i'm going to look into that
there's probably something to that
there's probably something to that $15
super chat from PR see no comment no
question thank you very much and a five
dollar super chat from Diego Diablo who
says some say this is a new era of
nationalism with Trump lepen etc others
say this rise in reactionaries is a
growing pain of a more interconnected
world I don't know that it's one or the
other nationalism you could see
something that is not nationalism per se
but is also not a reaction to an
interconnected world I i think that the
nationalism that we're seeing i read a
really interesting article actually
about nationalism which sort of
distinguishes between nationalism that
is a positive influence and nationalism
that is a negative influence and so for
example and an example of positive
nationalism would be pride in really
well designed and functional and
beautiful cities right wow my country
just has great cities with amazing
public transit and architecture etc
that's a great way to be sort of
nationalistic nationalism in the sense
of we're better than people from other
countries based on arbitrary lines that
have been
on that's not really good nationalism
okay so i might tweet that article out
it's a pretty interesting article okay
let's go to the next super chat we have
a five dollar super chap from Charisse
Walker hey David when I buy through your
link on amazon should there be something
that shows it did work no not at all you
go to david pakman.com slash amazon
it'll redirect you to amazon and then
everything you buy uh we get a little
kickback from and there should not be
anything per se that shows that it
worked you just go to david pakman.com
slash amazon five dollars super chat
from sean mahoney has producer pats
coffee daddy been identified yet there
there's so much backstory were it's a
brilliant question but there's so much
backstory the quick story was we were
talking about david pakman show coffee
on the show the other day which is
available at david pakman.com slash gear
and producer Pat I don't know if I want
to say admitted but because admitted
implies objectively that there's
something bad but stated that he uses
keyrings Keurig pods and it was just
insane explosion we saw people post
being on our reddit saying that I was
visibly shaken by the revelation etc and
then Pat clarified by saying I generally
use the reusable keyring pods but it
unless someone gives me the regular
curing pods and now what people want to
know is does pat have some kind of
keurig pod sugar daddy or sugar mama and
i have not gotten to the bottom of that
I've not gotten to the bottom of that so
I unfortunately don't have too much more
to say about it okay thank you to a
number of other new members including
Zach new begin a dolorous Rintoul and
Stephanie Walker all who signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership using
the coupon code i voted 17 membership
does come with daily commercial free
one-hour TV and radio show so instead of
watching our three
25 minute clips from the show on YouTube
which some people like some people would
rather the entire show you get a full
video that is just for our paid
subscribers we also do a daily bonus
show just for our paid subscribers as
well 15 to 20 minutes we talk about
other stories tomorrow we'll be talking
about this really pretty horrifying car
accident actually that Pat and I
witnessed last night okay so we talked
about that talked about some of the
stories talked about the DNC chair
election okay we've got great interviews
coming up I have finally made contact
with Natasha Dowie schull I recently
recommended the book addiction by design
which is about machine gambling meaning
video slots and video poker and how
casinos are designed to keep people
there and get them spending more money
etc absolutely fantastic book from
Princeton University Press I recommended
it on the show recently and she we
reached out to the author Natasha
Dashiell recently and she said that she
is going to she's interested in doing
the interview and we're just sort of
working on lining up the the dates at
this point so that is hugely exciting
also this week I will be running my
interview with Stefan Guillen a who's an
expert in the history of obesity dieting
diets cams etc etc so a lot of really
really good stuff coming up on the show
this week and I mean we've had a record
month on every platform last month we
had a record month on every platform and
then now we have another month that has
blown last month out of the water I'm
anticipating we're going to surpass 13
or maybe even 14 million YouTube views
which would be indeed a record for us we
may depending on being the 26 today
we've got just three days two and a half
days not even two days in a few hours
left for new members but we may get to
500 new paid subscribers in a single
month our prior record is like 200 okay
so more than doubling that and the
podcast also even though februari a
short month only two
days we've already days ago passed our
total month record for podcast downloads
couple other super chats clarf one two
three four two Australian dollar super
chat saying my friends in real life with
the co-hosts rest in peace Lewis yeah
just last night with producer Rachel
Gordon leaving we had a great little
outing with current producer Pat an
outgoing segment associate producer
Rachel and Ben Dixon went who hosts his
show out of our studio and bends in turn
it was it was a great time still in
touch with Lewis of course Louis a
childhood friend of mine and yes it's
all happening $20 super chat from
Chicago is my city do you think the
Russian involvement story is partly a
method of obfuscation from the
Democratic establishment they unwilling
to accept responsibility for having
simply a bad candidate that nobody
wanted to vote for well that's Donald
Trump's view a hold on a second we've
got the jew [ __ ] comments going that's
sort of like insta block I mean come on
it's we can't we can't have that
nonsense going on okay sorry for that
destructive this distraction folks
that's the Trump story Trump story is
that the entire Russia thing is meant to
distract from the fact that Hillary lost
the election and and what Chicago is my
city is suggesting as something similar
uh I don't know at this point who's
still talking about Hillary having lost
the election so it would be a very I
think you would be drawing more
attention to it I think it's a very very
bad it's a bad strategy if that's what
it is so the question of course being is
it partly that I just don't see this as
a story that's coming from the
Democratic establishment so is the
Democratic establishment in some way
benefiting from that and maybe it leads
to putting in the establishment
candidate is DNC chair Tom Perez maybe
but if it's if it's partial it's it's a
very very small percentage we've got a
fat five British Pound super chat from
Scott Porter who says do you think that
people should take an IQ test before
being eligible to vote seems like some
Trump supporters cannot understand even
simple facts we've talked about
context of uh parrot of uh parenting
should parenting have some kind of test
because hey listen the kids would
benefit from that I the problem with all
of those ideas even if they sound
somewhat logical at face value is that
they would invariably be uh they would
there's the the very real risk that they
would be applied in a way that would be
discriminatory based on class could be
based on race education etc etc so it's
it's pretty problematic uh five dollar
super chat from Andre Muse who says I
think the Russian involvement story is
all nonsense couldn't disagree with you
more I mean at this point uh listen
Andre here's the thing and I say this
with peace and love and I appreciate
that you've sent to super chats for a
total of ten dollars but as you know I
don't change or modify opinions based on
people contributing financially to the
show what aspect of the Russian
involvement story has been debunked so
far it's been the opposite we've it oh
just about every rumor regarding Russian
involvement has been partially or
completely verified so I am of the
mindset that increasingly I'm more and
more concerned about Russian involvement
with everything right i mean with with
um the you know the the the russian a
black male dossier first it's all fake
the dossier doesn't exist nobody was
briefed about the dossier we then learn
Oh actually yes the dossier exists
exists and Trump and Obama were briefed
about the dossier but the contents are
fake then we learned Oh actually some of
the contents aren't fake some of the
contents are real and tomorrow we've got
a story about even more of the content
contents being real so no I I completely
reject the notion that there's nothing
there okay a few new members I don't
know if I already thanked Cheryl more
but Cheryl more signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
coupon code i voted 17 jessica Bryce
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership also using the coupon code
I voted 17 uh it's very simple how this
coupon code works you get forty percent
off but you get a hundred percent of the
benefits pretty straightforward okay how
could that how could that go wrong ok we
are people a few comments people asking
that I mentioned that the david packard
show was looking into getting a drone
recently and have I made any decisions
on that yes indeed we have we we have
put in an order for the DJI mavic pro I
think that that's the way to go and you
can check out a picture by the way
please follow me on instagram i am on
instagram and that's where i put i think
the most interesting stuff i post in
some way is kind of on instagram and i'm
there at david pakman follow me there
you can check out a picture of the drone
that we're going to be getting I was
test-flying it and a lot of other
pictures me making empanadas me with a
corned beef sandwich etc etc and we're
going to be it's going to be great we're
gonna be able to travel with it and
we're going to be able to do a lot of
really great things a user named MS
PowerPoint sent a 200 currency super
chat but it's a currency I don't
recognize I don't know if that's Korean
no comment no question but thank you i
don't know how much 200 of your currency
is in u.s. dollars but it sounds pretty
high someone else saying that it's
indian rupees someone else saying it's
you on yeah i don't i don't know what
that is okay and hit by the way people
sing that Kyle's opinion is better about
the Trump Russia thing what does that
really mean it's what you're really
saying is you like his opinion better or
you agree with it but what does that
mean that it's objectively better I mean
I think that that what I just sometimes
I don't get what people are talking
about what does that mean okay what
somebody saying that 200 of that
currency is three US dollars alright
well there you go I appreciate it very
very much
okay listen we've talked about the
stories that are on tomorrow's show we
have given some amazing shoutouts to our
new members the coupon code I voted 17
continues we've had a lot of great super
chats I've mentioned that you should
follow me on instagram at david pakman
and on that note i'm actually going to
go i am making tonight uh seared tuna
rice bowls and i don't know how it's
going to come out but i'm gonna post a
picture of it for you later so thanks to
everybody who joined me the picture will
be on instagram at david pakman and
please do sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership